I'd like to take a moment and talk about the design of connectors.
As with components there is a design step required, particularly if you're
building your own connector. Starting from the overall architecture, of course
you determine your components and the required interactions among them. Then for
each interaction, determine what required services that interaction needs.
Once you've done that you can select a con, connector type that provides that
service. Each of the connector types has a variant of dimensions, variation
dimensions, that you can choose which of those variants you would like to have.
And from that, define your connector. And then you need to validate. And we'll
have one in a minute we'll, we'll describe some of the rules you can use for
checking whether or not the, the choices you made will work out.
And in doing this you may actually have to define your own connector.
You may not find one in the catalog or in available libraries that you can use.